okay so here there's an interesting
problem that you do see with with
scripts that maybe don't work that well
is they have talked but no dialogue talk
speed human speech can be poetic it can
be witty clever polite
moving but it isn't dialogue unless
there's there's action under it and
that's that's something to look for
there's really two elements of a
dialogue that you can learn about it
isn't it isn't simply a talent some
people have a natural talent they can
ear for it and they capture it but it
goes beyond that you can actually learn
how to do this and buy action well let
me explain it this way in a dramatic
scene you'll often find not a dramatic
scene in the scene the problem is no
drama the students will come with cue in
it what I call cue a dialogue how are
you today okay how about you we're not
bad I think I'll go to the store what
about you I think I'll not go to the
store you know what that's that's cue a
dialogue now and it's it doesn't really
qualify as dialogue it's useful to think
of dialogue especially in the rewrite
stage and I'd emphasize that and the
first draft pour it on a page and don't
worry if it's Q&A dialogue don't worry
about it it'll only block you up if you
worry about it but once it's on the page
and you're thinking if it's working but
everybody loves it you say we're done if
it isn't working there are some
diagnostic tools you can use to study
your dialogue and see what you can do
with it
there is this concept of subtext and
dialogue and I'll have to give you a
warning that I use the term in a way
different from pretty much everybody
else I've seen that used like in the
McKee book he talks about subtext and
dialogue and there's a there's a passage
of mary says well let's say you have two
lovers and there
at a table and it's beautiful and you
know the candle lit and one says to the
other darling I love you I love you I
love you and he says well that's not
octuple because it's two of them knows
what I'm gonna style up and he says well
that really needs to be subtext you need
some text and it'd be better if you give
them an action and he's example of a
couple that's repairing him a flat tire
and we get from that action that they're
in love but they don't ever say it okay
so I mean I look at that I think I have
a feeling I've been in that situation
where I've been with some of and I said
I love to him and it was active all so
they did it why isn't it active oh well
that version of subtext what it means
I've never found very helpful I get the
idea
okay you want to say things without
saying it otherwise it's too on-the-nose
but I think it's more useful to think of
subtext as the underlying format what am
i doing what am i doing in the scene and
actors asked what am i doing and
dialogue is action with words that's all
it is it's somebody doing something but
they're using words instead of actions
physical actions and so it's a useful
thing when you have a scene that's
already written to just see whether you
can reduce each line of dialogue to a
verb
and the kind of verbs you're looking for
are things like attack defend deflect
persuade seduce those are the kinds of
verbs you want the lines to have okay
you don't want explain it's just
emotionally neutral and that's where the
Q&A thing comes in so if you have the
dialogue how are you today and the
person says well I didn't sleep much
last night
that's Q&A but if you have a character
who says you look like hell and they say
well I didn't sleep much last night you
see now you've got attack defense hey I
didn't sleep much so you transform it
into something that's actually moves
that actually is dynamic and we're
following action and that's that's the
other thing if you want to know what
people what's in there
play that works that gets people going
one other element is that people follow
action which is somebody doing something
or something doing something and even in
your description you keep that in mind
that in a stage play you're gonna list
all this stuff that's on the stage but
in a movie you want a character to walk
through a room and pass by a you know
fancy couch with a cat on it and move to
and picked up a you know you want it to
be all contained within action because
people watch that
so that's subtext I think it's useful
way of thinking of subtext
it's what's the action what's the verb
that's underlying it and that's you can
stray from that a little bit but most of
the time you want that to be the case
you want to be able to identify what is
the person doing the question of
on-the-nose dialogue is not related to
subtext on the notes dialogue is defined
as characters say exactly what they are
thinking and it's straightforward and
it's boring so in that example okay man
says to the woman I love you I love you
I love you man okay so that is that's a
bit on the nose let's say but the the
way to attack that again is in the
rewrite stage not when you're trying to
come up with it is there are simple
there are literary devices that are
ancient that you can employ and the
easiest one is irony you take a
character who says you look like hell
okay that's a straightforward attack and
says you look beautiful just flip it
completely upside down and they'll be
like what do you mean I couldn't sleep
last night you know if they'll be defend
themselves because they're gonna get it
there's a lot of human interaction is
ironic and there's we talked about in
the other book the science of
screenwriting that there's there are
theories that human beings in order to
function as a society need to have
plausible deniability
you need to test things out around an
explosive issue like sex I mean what if
you're interested in somebody but you're
not sure you should ask them
out because maybe there's a problem so
you could go up to them and tell them a
story about there was this guy I know
and he was in love with this girl but
she was already involved with somebody
and you know and the other the target of
the seduction may know exactly they're
talking about her but if the person says
I'm married it says mom and say no I'm
just telling a story see but so you have
irony irony is basically saying two
opposite things at the same time and
like it's it's pouring rain I love this
weather and people get it or nice shoes
you got there
and people people ago what's wrong with
them you know they're gonna understand
it it's in the tone and the way you do
it but it's like I didn't say anything I
just said they're nice shoes that's all
so irony is a useful one and there's
trouble in paradise again a great movie
that everybody should watch but there is
a scene where there's two guys that are
rivals for the same woman and one of
them goofed up and what you know he lost
something that belonged to her on a date
and so the other guys riding him so what
do they they they they meet each other
in the in a shop where there you can buy
another one of what she was a person
then the guy comes in he says oh how are
you doing major does mmm you know and
then he says you're looking fine major
he said I've had enough of your
insulting remarks and write it it works
really well okay so irony is one then
another one is metaphor that you'll see
people speaking and people do this a lot
so instead of subtext I think a
preferred term would be indirection it's
indirect speech or sometimes you could
call it conflicted speech speech that's
rich because it has double meanings and
a great example that I like from the
Double Indemnity picture
it's a very famous scene in which a man
is interested in a married woman and he
said all he says is when she says my
husband don't be back at 8 o'clock he
says he implies I don't want to see him
anymore or see you and she says there's
a speed limit in this state mr. Neff 45
miles an hour
and he says how fast was I going officer
she says I'd say about 90 why'd you get
off your motorcycle give me a ticket
suppose I let you off with a warning
this time you know the whole thing is
carried on indirectly through metaphor
and that is a powerful way of doing it
plus he can say hey I was just talking
about traffic I was talking about we
need to get I wasn't going after your
wife it's fine so that's part of the
reason you have it but also having it in
your script makes it richer makes it
like wow this is really pop and powerful
and that's the other thing to keep in
mind about a screenplay as opposed to a
novel is it's a limited amount of time
so it has to be richer everything they
say a novel is drama a novel is gossip
drama is scandal you know everybody is
instead of walking you're running so if
you have dialogue it's precious and you
want it to be rich so indirection can
help another one is and by the way in
the social network is a great study if
you want to look at how dialogue is done
with indirection
he uses irony and an awful lot and a
character saying I'm heartbroken about
that and you know that he's just
bullshitting them or somebody saying oh
this is really classy you know the but
said indirectly I've let me let the
classiness waft over me one character
says and it's clear he's mean it's not
or another one is cease and desist
letter you know I guess that cease and
desist letter really scared the [ __ ] out
of him but he means it didn't have any
effect all he did all of the circuits
that did was flip them into irony but he
also uses metaphor okay well if these
two characters want to stand on my
shoulders and pretend they're tall
that's fine well they're not they're
they're big they're not going to show me
but he's using metaphor right metonymy
if something stands for something else
again going back to the social network
it's he tells a story about the founder
of the founder of Victoria's Secret who
sold out too soon he could have made
five hundred million he only made five
million so he threw himself off the
Golden Gate Bridge right that's a story
that's told and then he tells Mark
Zuckerberg character you know you don't
want to sell it too soon because the
waters of the Golden Gate are very cold
he doesn't have to say that it's that
you're gonna regret this that's on the
nose silence don't sell out too soon
because you're gonna regret this
if you say that the waters under are
cold then that's a much more powerful
way of doing it and that's metonymy is
something standing for for something
else in the class of things you know the
bridge stands for suicide or depression
or failure so that's that's what you can
do to make dialogue not on the nose and
I would say subtext you want in every
line if you can in direction is more
like spice you add it as needed and look
for opportunities but people don't use
it all the time so you don't need to use
it all the time well even in sharp
objects where amy adams goes back to the
little town that she was raised and she
doesn't really want to be there and she
says in the beginning you know when they
say you know bless your heart that
doesn't mean what it means it basically
means the opposite right and that's
what's so great about the show too is a
lot of stuff is caged in this sweetness
right but it doesn't mean it in fact it
is with I think your name is Eudora the
fantastic character played by Patricia
Clarkson Patricia Clarkson is the mother
and she is so skilled at that that kind
of dialogue where a lot of stuff is said
to kind of take the power away from
different characters and it's done so
well yeah well there's a movie I
recently I saw recently again going back
a little further it's called bad day at
Black Rock with Ben sir Tracy and it's
not a Western
set in Arizona but it's not a Western
and it involves a guy showing up in this
small town where people nobody's been
the Train has not stopped in the last
three years and it's something that's
off this guy usually goes right on
through nobody comes to Black Rock
anymore and everybody's acting real
suspicious who is this guy what does he
want
and they he's trying to get information
to go find somebody and the moment they
mentioned the name it's like nobody
wants to help him so the dialogue is
very functional the indirect dialogue is
very functional because he can't say
okay did somebody murder them what
happened did somebody murder him what
what's going on here
he's got to ask questions and they don't
want to give him a lot of answers so
it's all this maneuverable maneuvering
and it's a sight to behold how they
pulled that off it's worth it's exciting
movie but it's also worth looking at
just for the the way in Direction is
used asking questions without asking
them answering them giving warnings to
people without warning them that kind of
thing so it makes for rich screenwriting
so that would be another element if the
dialogue is has power to it I mean the
power in the sense of action and is not
all on the nose that it uses in
direction and the subtleties the way
humans actually do talk then it's gonna
be more successful and that's it it just
takes practice and it just takes
rewriting that's all it's not it's not
that hard to do actually especially
irony just look at look at your stuff
and see what happens if the character
says the opposite and and find out
you